[Music]
nobody's face is too complicated to turn
into a pastry for the most part
i make pies of people that i like and
respect
and it's cool if other people like and
respect them too that's always a nice
bonus
people like the country music television
or the turner network or places like
that
have called me up and asked me to make
pies for dolly parton
and dakota fanning and just like
random interesting people i did realize
the hard way
that you have to pick a pie dough that's
not going to warp
and puff up in the oven if you're doing
someone's likeness
certain types of pie like if you've got
an all butter pie with
let's say carbonated water in it it's
going to puff up which is
nice and delicious but if it's
somebody's face you don't want them to
have like a big
goiter or you know strange
pastry tumors all over their face so
when i'm doing um
people i usually do shortening based
pies because it doesn't puff up
for the ones that's just somebody's face
on a pie that takes about an hour
but then for some of the pie scrapers
like the multi-tiered pies that i do
those can take a couple of days
if they didn't taste as good as they
look i would not be doing this
[Music]
i've gotten requests for people to um
have their own portrait with a celebrity
it was them getting married
to this person i'm like i don't know
about that
for the most part people are fairly you
know they look at things that i've
already made and they're like
i like that
you